is there any real mystery that you're
picking trevor lawrence
uh i'd have to say that's the direction
we're going and
i'll leave that up to the owner when we
make that decision official
but i i'm certainly not stepping out of
line that that's certainly the direction
we're headed
[Music]
peter king talking to urban meyer the
latest edition of the peter king podcast
and i i think that urban meyer
understands
the basic nfl preference thou shalt not
tip your hand because we need the
ultimate reality show on april 29 to
have maximum drama even if everyone
knows you're taking trevor lawrence you
came away from that conversation
believing even more strongly than ever
before they're taking trevor lawrence
look everybody 93
people who follow football thought that
there was a 93 to 95 chance
that they're taking trevor lawrence
after seeing what urban meyer said to me
uh
there's a 99 percent chance maybe a
hundred percent chance that they're
taking them but mike i think
over the years you're absolutely right
i'm sure that roger goodell read those
quotes on monday morning and thought ah
urban come on you got to play the game
but
one of the one of the issues one of the
issues with playing the game that we're
talking about right here
is that look jacksonville is a little
bit of a different place right now
uh they it it's it's really important
for the fans in jacksonville to get
totally absolutely fired up i think
you're gonna see the jaguars do
something really fun
uh
maybe even unprecedented with trevor
lawrence i have no idea what it's gonna
be but i think they're really gonna try
to capitalize
on trevor fever
uh the last weekend of april when he is
drafted by the jaguars because look the
jaguars are down they are a down
franchise and they need to create
a lot of excitement in jacksonville so i
mean to me
i can't find any fault with urban meyer
taking the drama away from that first
pick now
some might say
so it's a lot more fun if it's the new
york jets because new york is 900 times
the size of jacksonville so there's
going to be more intense interest nowing
that now knowing that in essence the new
york jets are on the clock
and the 49ers generating a ton of
interest with everyone wondering what
they're going to do at number three and
i think that's one of the reasons why
you continue to press your cards close
to the vest because part of what you do
when you trade up and i said this in the
past about jeff fisher in 2016 when the
rams moved up to number one and everyone
knew they were taking jared goff he
wasn't going to say it because you
create some mystery and then everyone's
talking about the rams in the run-up to
the draft how else do you get that kind
of publicity and that kind of attention
especially when you're a team that's
been struggling so 49ers even though
they haven't struggled
in the you know
extended past last year wasn't great for
them they've moved up and now they get
to be in the spotlight with the jets as
we try to guess what they're going to do
here's my conspiracy theory peter
the zack wilson pro day was last friday
trevor lawrence did not attend and there
it is
trevor lawrence did not i'm not trevor
lawrence now i'm all flustered because
there's conspiracy mike i don't smoke
cigarettes that's a photoshop anyway
urban meyer didn't attend the zack
wilson pro day my theory is especially
the way he explained to you and he
explained at a press conference how he
likes to be there hover over the
quarterback hear the ball come out of
the hand
he didn't want
to experience that with zach wilson
because he doesn't want to complicate
his life he doesn't want to clutter his
brain he doesn't want to entertain any
doubts that maybe wilson is the guy they
should take instead of lawrence what do
you think of that
i mean
look that would be the ultimate that
would be the greatest smoke screen in
history
period i mean
why on earth
uh if if
if for some reason the jacksonville
jaguars take zach wilson just imagine
what would happen that would be first of
all
it would be incredible ratings because
everybody
may not have been tuned in to the
television on april 29
at 8 11 p.m
you know when roger goodell steps up and
says the jaguars select
from brigham young quarterback zach
wilson well i guarantee you that there
will be
10 million fans who at that moment or in
the five minutes afterwards are going to
go to their tvs and say what the bleep
just happened
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports